Un día en educación física, me pisó y se negó a disculparse.
Llena de rabia, lo agarré y lo tiré contra el suelo.
Había hecho judo anteriormente.
(Risas)
Nuestra pelea duró menos de dos minutos
pero fue el reflejo perfecto del huracán
que se creaba dentro de mí
como joven superviviente de agresión sexual
y una chica que estaba lidiando con el abandono
y expuesta a la violencia en otros ámbitos de mi vida.
Estaba peleando con él
pero también luchaba contra los hombres y chicos que agredieron mi cuerpo
y la cultura que me dijo que debía guardar silencio.
Un profesor disolvió la pelea
y mi directora me llamó a su oficina.
Pero no dijo: "Monique, ¿qué está mal contigo?"
Me dio un momento para recobrar el aliento
y preguntó: ¿Qué pasó?"
Los educadores que trabajaban conmigo dirigían con empatía.
Me conocían.
Sabían que amaba leer, sabían que amaba dibujar,
sabían que adoraba a Prince.
Y usaron esa información para ayudarme a comprender
que mis acciones, y las de mi compañero, eran problemáticas
para la comunidad educativa que dirigían.
No me pusieron en suspensión;
no llamaron a la policía.
Mi pelea no me impidió ir a la escuela al día siguiente.
No me impidieron graduarme; no me impidieron enseñar.
Desafortunadamente, esa no es la historia que comparten muchas chicas negras
hoy en día en EE.UU. y en el mundo.
Vivimos una crisis en la que las chicas negras
son desproporcionalmente forzadas a abandonar las escuelas
no por la amenaza inminente que representan para su seguridad,
sino porque a menudo experimentan las escuelas
como lugares de castigo y marginalización.
Es algo que escucho de chicas negras de todo el país.
Pero no es insuperable.
Podemos cambiar esta historia.
Empecemos con algunos datos.
De acuerdo con el análisis del National Black Women Justice Institute
de datos sobre derechos civiles
recopilados por el Departamento de Educación de EE.UU.,
las chicas negras son el único grupo de chicas sobrerrepresentado
a lo largo del espectro de la disciplina en la escuela.
Esto no significa que otras chicas no sean llamadas a disciplinarse
y no significa que otras chicas no estén sobrerrepresentadas
en otras partes de ese espectro.
Pero las chicas negras son el único grupo
representado en exceso por costumbre.
Las chicas negras son siete veces más propensas que sus contrapartes blancas
a experimentar una o más suspensiones
y casi tres veces más propensas que sus contrapartes blancas y latinas
a ser enviadas a la corte juvenil.
Un estudio reciente del Georgetown Center on Poverty and Inequality
explicó parcialmente por qué ocurre esta disparidad
cuando confirmaron que experimentan
una supresión especial relacionada con la edad,
donde son vistas como más adultas que sus iguales blancos.
Entre otras cosas, el estudio descubrió
que la gente percibe que las chicas negras necesitan menos crianza,
menos protección para saber más sobre el sexo
y ser más independientes que sus pares blancas.
El estudio también descubrió
que la percepción de disparidad empieza cuando las chicas tienen cinco años.
Y que esta percepción y la disparidad se incrementan con el tiempo
y alcanzan su cenit cuando las chicas tienen entre 10 y 14 años.
Esto no ocurre sin consecuencias.
Creer que una chica es mayor de lo que es lleva a un trato más severo,
censura inmediata cuando comete un error
y culpar a la víctima cuando está lastimada.
Puede llevarla a pensar que hay algo mal con ella,
en lugar de las condiciones en las que se encuentra.
Las chicas negras son habitualmente vistas como muy ruidosas, muy agresivas,
muy enfadadas, muy visibles.
Cualidades que son a menudo comparadas en relación con chicas no negras
y que no tienen en cuenta qué está ocurriendo en la vida de esta chica
o en sus normas culturales.
Y no es solo en EE.UU.
En Sudáfrica,
las chicas negras de la Pretoria High School
fueron disuadidas de ir a la escuela con su cabello al natural,
sin un procesamiento químico.
¿Qué hicieron estas chicas?
Protestaron.
Y fue hermoso ver que la mayor parte de la comunidad global
apoyó a estas chicas mientras se alzaban en su verdad.
Pero hubo quienes las vieron como problemáticas,
en gran parte porque se atrevieron a hacer la pregunta:
"¿Dónde podemos ser negros si no podemos ser negros en África?"
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Es una buena pregunta.
En todo el mundo,
chicas negras lidian con esta pregunta.
chicas negras luchan por ser vistas, trabajan para ser libres
y pelean por ser incluidas
en el panorama de la promesa que ofrece un espacio seguro para aprender.
En EE.UU., las niñas, apenas han pasado sus primeros años,
son arrestadas en aulas por tener una rabieta.
Las chicas de secundaria son separadas de la escuela
por la forma en que llevan su cabello al natural
o por la forma en que la ropa se ajusta a su cuerpo
Las chicas de secundaria experimentan violencia
a manos de oficiales de policía en las escuelas.
¿Dónde pueden ser negras las chicas negras sin reprimenda o castigo?
Y no son solo estos incidentes.
En mi trabajo como investigadora y educadora,
tuve una oportunidad de trabajar con chicas como Stacy,
una chica a la que me refiero en mi libro "Pushout",
que lucha con su participación en la violencia.
Ella pasa por alto los análisis neurocientíficos y estructurales
que la ciencia tiene que ofrecer
sobre cómo sus experiencias adversas en la infancia explican
por qué ella participa en la violencia
y directamente se describe a sí misma como "chica problemática",
en gran parte por el lenguaje que usan los educadores
cuando la suspenden habitualmente.
Pero esta es la cuestión.
La desconexión e internalización del dolor se fortalece en la marginación.
Cuando las chicas se meten en problemas, no deberíamos apartarlas
deberíamos acercarlas más.
La educación es un factor crítico de protección
contra el contacto con el sistema legal criminal.
Deberíamos estar construyendo políticas y prácticas
que mantengan a las chicas conectadas con su aprendizaje,
en lugar de alejarlas de él.
Es una de las razones por la que me gusta decir que la educación
es un trabajo de libertad.
Cuando las chicas se sienten seguras, pueden aprender.
Cuando no se sienten seguras, pelean,
protestan, discuten, huyen, se bloquean.
El cerebro humano está preparado para protegernos de una amenaza.
Y mientras la escuela parezca una amenaza,
o parte del tapiz del daño en la vida de una chica,
estará inclinada a resistirse.
Pero cuando las escuelas se convierten en lugares de curación,
también pueden convertirse en lugares de aprendizaje.
¿Qué significa que la escuela se convierte en lugar de curación?
En primer lugar, supone que tenemos que suprimir inmediatamente
las políticas y prácticas que señalan a las chicas negras por su cabello o vestido.
(Aplausos)
Centrémonos en cómo y qué aprende una chica
en vez de vigilar su cuerpo de manera que facilite la cultura de la violación
o castigar a los niños por las condiciones en las que nacieron.
Aquí es donde los padres y la comunidad de adultos pueden participar.
Empezar una conversación con la escuela
y animarlos a examinar su código de vestimenta
y otras políticas relacionadas con la conducta como proyecto colaborativo,
con padres y estudiantes,
para evitar intencionalmente el sesgo y la discriminación.
Tengan en cuenta
que algunas de las prácticas que dañan a las chicas negras no están escritas.
Tenemos que seguir haciendo un trabajo interno profundo para abordar los sesgos
que informen cómo, cuándo y si vemos a las chicas negras como realmente son,
o como nos han contado que son.
Sean voluntarios en una escuela
y establezcan grupos de discusión competentes a nivel cultural y de género
con chicas negras, latinas, chicas indígenas
y otros estudiantes que experimenten marginación en las escuelas
para darles un espacio seguro
para procesar sus identidades y experiencias en escuelas.
Y si las escuelas se convierten en lugares de curación,
tenemos que eliminar a los policías
y aumentar el número de consejeros en las escuelas.
(Aplausos)
La educación es un trabajo de libertad.
Y cualquiera que sea nuestro punto de ingreso, debemos luchar por la libertad.
Las buenas noticias es que hay escuelas
que trabajan activamente para establecerse
como lugares para que las chicas se vean como algo sagrado y querido.
La Columbus City Prep School for Girls en Columbus, Ohio, es un ejemplo de esto.
Se convirtió en un ejemplo desde el momento que su director declaró
que ya no iba a castigar a las chicas por tener "mala actitud".
Además de construir...
Esencialmente, desarrollaron un espectro sólido
de alternativas a la suspensión, expulsión y arresto.
Además de establecer un programa de justicia restaurativa,
mejoraron sus relaciones alumno-profesor
asegurando que cada chica tenga al menos un adulto en el campus
al que pueda acudir cuando esté en un momento de crisis.
Construyeron espacios a lo largo de los pasillos de la escuela y aulas
para que las chicas se reagrupen, si necesitan un minuto.
Y establecieron un programa de asesoramiento para dar a las chicas
una oportunidad
de empezar cada día con la promoción de la autoestima,
habilidades de comunicación y establecer metas.
En esta escuela
tratan de responder a las experiencias adversas de la infancia de una chica
en lugar de ignorarlas.
Las acercan más, no las alejan.
Y como resultado, sus tasas de ausentismo y suspensión han mejorado,
y las chicas llegan a la escuela más dispuestas a aprender
porque saben que sus profesores se preocupan por ellas.
Eso importa.
Escuelas que integran las artes y los deportes en su currículum
o están desarrollando un programa transformativo,
como justicia restaurativa, conciencia plena y meditación,
están brindando oportunidades a las chicas de reparar su relación con otros,
pero también consigo mismas.
Respondiendo al trauma vivido, complejo e histórico
que enfrentan los estudiantes
requiere que todos los que creemos en la promesa de niños y adolescentes
construyamos relaciones, aprendamos materiales,
recursos humanos y financieros y otras herramientas
que brinden a los niños oportunidad de curarse, para que puedan aprender.
Nuestras escuelas deberían ser lugares donde responder a las chicas vulnerables
como algo esencial para la creación de una cultura escolar positiva.
Nuestra habilidad de ver su promesa debería ser más incisiva
cuando está en el camino de la pobreza y la adicción;
cuando se recupera de ser víctima de trata sexual
o sobrevivió otras formas de violencia;
cuando está en lo más alto,
o en lo más bajo.
Debemos ser capaces de apoyar su bienestar
intelectual y socioemocional
si sus pantalones llegan a su rodilla, o al muslo o más allá.
Puede parecer una tarea difícil en un mundo
tan profundamente arraigado en la política del miedo
imaginar a las escuelas como lugares donde las chicas se curen y prosperen,
pero debemos ser suficientemente audaces para establecer nuestra intención.
Si nos comprometemos con esta noción de educación como trabajo de libertad
podemos cambiar las condiciones educativas
para que ninguna chica, incluso la más vulnerable de nosotras,
salga de la escuela.
Y eso es una victoria para todos nosotros.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)